PROFESSOR: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
Last time in lecture
you started learning
about implicit differentiation.
And you saw some examples of
how implicit differentiation can
be used to compute
derivatives of functions
defined implicitly.
So let's do another
example today.
So here I have a curve that's
defined by the implicit
equation y cubed plus
x cubed equals 3x*y.
And I'd like to
know what the slope
of the tangent
line to that curve
is at the point (4/3, 2/3).
So before we start
doing anything,
let me just make a
couple of observations.
If you don't believe me,
that the point (4/3, 2/3)
is on this curve, you can always
check by plugging the values in
and confirm that really, yes,
4/3 cubed plus 2/3 cubed is
equal to 3 times 2/3 times 4/3.
So it's-- how I found this
point is maybe a little magical.
Because as you can
see, this equation
is really a tough
one to solve for y.
What you sort of--
natural thing to want
to do when asked this
question is to solve for y
and get an equation for
y in terms of x and then
take the derivative using the
various differentiation rules
that you've learned.
But here, this is-- I'll
let you in a secret.
There is a way to do this.
But it's really hard.
It's really ugly and it's
beyond the scope of this course.
So really we're much
better off treating
this as an implicit
differentiation problem
than as an explicit
differentiation problem.
So having said that, why don't
you take a minute or two.
Try and have a go
at this yourself.
And then we'll come back and
work through it together.
All right, so welcome back.
We were in the middle-- we were
just about to start, actually--
solving this problem, computing
the slope of the tangent line
to the curve y cubed plus
x cubed equals 3x*y at this
point, (4/3, 2/3).
So the slope of the tangent
line is the value y prime
of x at that point.
So we need to answer
this question.
What we need to do is we need
to find the derivative of y.
But as I said earlier, this
is tough to do explicitly,
to find y in terms of
x, so we're going to use
implicit differentiation.
So, so we start
with this equation,
y cubed plus x cubed equals 3x*y
and we can take a derivative
with respect to x.
So some parts--
all right, so let's
start with it in the
order it's given.
So you have y cubed.
If you take a derivative of y
cubed with respect to x, what
you need to use the chain
rule because y is implicitly
a function of x and so y
cubed is the chain rule.
It's the cubed function
applied to the y function.
And this is true of implicit
differentiation in general.
That the reason
that we can do this,
the really fundamental
reason this works
is that we have the chain rule
and that it lets us evaluate
derivatives of compositions.
So in our case we have,
so we take a derivative
of the whole thing, of this
whole I'm going to write,
this is a little
sloppy notation,
but I hope you know what I mean.
We have this
identity and so we're
going to take a derivative
of the whole thing.
And so the first
part on the left, we
get the derivative of y cubed.
So by the chain
rule, so we first
take the derivative of
the cube function at y
and then multiply by
the derivative of y.
So this is the
derivative of y cubed.
It just gives us 3 y squared.
So that's what happens when you
just deal with the cubed part.
But then we need to multiply
by-- in the chain rule--
by the derivative of the inside.
Which in this
context is dy by dx.
OK.
Plus the derivative of x cubed.
That's more straightforward.
Nothing really
complicated going on here.
We've seen this for
a little while now.
It's just 3x squared equal--
OK.
So on the right now, we don't
actually have a chain rule,
we have a product
rule situation here.
We have 3 times x times y.
So 3 is just a constant.
And so we could just
pull it out in front.
So we take the
derivative of x*y.
So we take the derivative of
the first times the second
plus the derivative of the
second times the first.
So the derivative of
the first is just--
ah sorry, x is the first,
so its derivative is 1.
So we got 3 times
the second is y.
Plus-- OK, so we
take the first times
the derivative of the
second, which is dy by dx.
So because this is
an identity it holds
for all values of x and y.
This equality follows
just by taking
the derivative of both sides.
Good.
So now the thing
we want is that we
want the slope of the tangent
line at a particular point.
So we want to isolate dy/dx.
That's the thing
we're trying to find.
So here, if you're only
interested in dy/dx,
this is actually a linear
equation in some sense, right?
We have dy/dx, a
constant, something--
or, it's not a constant--
something times dy/dx
plus something equals something
plus something times dy/dx.
There are no squares of
dy/dx is what I really mean.
So OK.
So that that's nice.
It makes it relatively
easier to solve,
so we can just combine all
the terms with dy/dx in them.
Let's say we'll combine maybe,
put them over here and put
everything else over there.
So over here we
get, so dy/dx, so we
have a 3 y squared minus a 3x.
And on the other side we have
a 3y minus a 3 x squared.
And so this is times,
multiplication there.
And so we want dy by
dx just by itself.
So we can just divide through
by 3 y squared minus 3x.
So then we have dy/dx
is equal to-- well,
all right, so there
are a lot of 3's here.
There's a constant
multiple of 3 on this side,
a constant multiple
of 3 on this side.
Those are going to cancel.
So this is y minus x squared
over y squared minus x.
OK, so at any point
(x, y) on this curve,
the slope of the tangent line is
given by this expression here.
And we're interested
in a particular point
in this problem.
We're interested in the
point 4/3 comma 2/3.
So at let me take that back up
here so at the point 4/3 comma
2/3 we have dy by dx.
So OK, we just we just
plug that value of y
and that value of x into
this formula that we've got.
So that's 2/3 minus 4/3
squared is 16/9 over-- well,
let's see, 2/3 squared
is 4/9 minus 4/3.
All right, so we have a
little bit of rational number
arithmetic here.
Maybe I'll multiply top
and bottom through by 9
to get 6 minus 16
over 4 minus 12.
So this is negative 10 over
negative 8, which is 5 over 4.
And if we go back to
the picture that I drew,
it actually looks pretty
reasonable over here, right?
This slope of this
tangent line is actually
a little bit bigger than 1.
Great.
So that's that.